have you seen hunter biden's hard drive
or his
more recently broken cell phone his
entire icloud account if you haven't
seen it
don't do not look i saw a link going
around twitter i clicked on it i think i
have seen more naked images of hunter
biden than i have seen
of my own body i've seen naked looking
in the mirror in the bathroom i mean
this guy
i looked i said okay is that
i see like two or three photos i say
i've got to look away
but i do want to find out
about the crimes that he has committed
and more importantly i want to find out
about any crimes potentially that go all
the way up to the big guy numero uno mr
joe to help me parse all of this and to
save me from having to actually look at
the laptop and the cell phone is my
friend jack bosovic the senior editor at
human events and a tpusa host jack thank
you for being here
michael i've seen things i've seen
things that i cannot unsee things from
the other side things that are
uh
most likely in the service of moloch um
this content
this is godlessness right this is a this
is a man who who never had god in his
life uh his father is supposedly this
nominal catholic and yet we don't see
any
er embl
not even a sign of any catholic or any
type of religious
you know uh upbringing right in his son
right and and i say this as look you
know people struggle with addiction sure
i i get and i'm sympathetic to that but
we what we've seen on this laptop and
this hard drive i've had a copy of it
for two years now uh the cell phone is
it's a lot of a lot of it's
it's more but it typically it tends to
be more of along the same vein right not
only the licentiousness the fornication
uh prostitution but also these financial
wheelings and dealings that go in with
ukraine with china with russia in many
cases and
you know just to say as a prior intel
guy when i was in the navy
if i were working for the chinese mss or
the russian fsb and i was looking for i
don't know potentially a way to
influence you know american politics and
i was looking for perhaps a a node into
one of the major political families in
the in the country right this would be
the guy this would easily be the number
one guy that we would go after you you
could set up all sorts of blackmail
operations honeypot operations on this
guy and it would tie directly back to
the father because of course the
financial uh the financial ties are all
there and so the issue is it isn't so
much about you know is um the the first
son being being blackmailed we know we
know that he has the financial ties
there we know that he's been with x
amount of uh foreign escorts shall we
say if we're going to be nice about it
um the real question is
why isn't it at this point i'm basically
at this point michael
why hasn't there been
an acknowledgement of this grand jury
that's opened in
supposedly in delaware under the u.s
attorney that we're told was supposed to
be a tax right they said it was a tax
investigation that's what hunter tried
to say right after the election is very
quiet right because everyone's talking
about you know is trump was it going to
be recounted etc very quietly hunter
biden came out and said well i'm under
tax investigation no no no he's actually
under federal investigation for his
foreign financial wieldings and dealings
that's number one but number two this is
a guy who's been in the white house as
recently as this week he was at the us
uh the the medal of freedom ceremony and
he's talking to senator lieberman he's
talking to cindy mccain right he's right
there front row right do we know that he
has how does he able to get so close to
the president what is his level of
communication with the president when we
know there's clearly issues here and by
the way right and i don't want to go
full russiagate on this thing and say oh
there's a dossier and you know
everything else but you'd you'd like to
know hopefully that the highest office
in our land is protected by a layer of
people that are being a little bit
proactive into someone who's clearly a
target for foreign intelligence
operations well i don't think you have
to worry about going russiagate we were
told with russiagate that there were
photos and videos of donald trump doing
all sorts of things with hookers in
foreign hotel rooms
i i don't need to wonder if that's the
case with hunter biden
we've all seen the videos we've really
seen the photos
right it's it's we were it's it's he is
everything that the media told us that
donald trump jr and donald trump senior
were right he is all of those things to
a t every single one of them and there's
no question about it and my favorite
part of this
actually and i tweeted this yesterday
was that i love how the left they hate
the rich right
down with the rich eat the rich aoc's
got the dress on and everything i hate
the rich i can't stand the rich unless
your name is hunter biden in which case
you know go do what you want you're
right right no so this raises a few
different questions
one
i don't really care about hunter biden's
personal life this is actually why i was
able to to
convince myself that i don't need to
look at these videos and photos is one i
thought it's not good for my soul to see
these things and two i'm not sure
that there's much of a purpose being
served here because look it's just
hunter it's this degenerate sun but then
you raise this point you say
this is a real blackmail risk this is a
real extortion risk uh this is a guy who
has been committing crimes on camera
it's not just that he's getting a little
frisky with his wife and puts it puts
his laptop open he's the guy's
committing crimes on camera
and the crimes are almost inseparable
from
the financial crimes the weird sex stuff
is taking place within the context of
this broader foreign corruption where is
he getting the money for these
shenanigans well he's getting it from
overseas powers he's getting from
ukraine he's getting it from china the
enabling that we see right and so so i
guess my question for people who aren't
going to go through seven zillion
terabytes of hunter biden's gross hard
drives yeah no one recommends that
what
what are the big crimes here what should
we be worried about what is the
connection to joe biden if one does
exist
what is the issue i just don't want
people to to get buried in an avalanche
of tabloid stuff and then miss the
actual crimes
right so the actual crimes in this
situation and it does go back to some of
the things that we've known for years
and some of this was originally reported
by places like politico by the new york
times and others
this idea that he was getting
50 000
a month from it from barisma right it's
a name that you suddenly don't hear
anymore which is this ukrainian oil
company controlled by ukrainian
oligarchs while his father was the vice
president we also know again that he's
tied in in china with this group called
bhr investments and they are heavily
invested in cynopex sinopec is the ccp's
that's their that's their gas company
right that's their that's their
state-owned gas enterprise he's invested
in it
that's the same gas comp that's the same
company that president biden is selling
our oil to from the strategic petroleum
reserve so you really do have to put all
this together and say
why is it that the financial dealings of
hunter biden who is a guy that
doesn't look like anybody anyone that
anyone would want to ever do business
with right what possible expertise could
he be offering the ukrainian oligarchs
the oligarchs of the ccp that had the
apparatchiks of of the politburo right
other than access to his father and
access to politics right if this is the
stuff and come on you know you know he's
not hiding this everyone in his family
knows what he's doing his father clearly
knows what he's doing we can see the
text messages his wife his ex-wife knew
what he was doing his uh at one point in
some of the videos and in the text
messages you can see he was um carrying
on a relationship with his uh the widow
of his brother so his brother's widow uh
carrying our relationship which included
drugs while children were in the home
right we could that's that's all child
endangerment by the way in the state of
delaware last time i checked and i
believe in all 50 states as a matter of
fact even california yes i believe they
do have some you know obscure 1800s law
still in the book about that you know
they haven't uh haven't gotten rid of
all i've been enforced in a while
newsome will probably hear this and then
take action right
swift action but
the the issue then becomes obviously
he's selling influence with his father
and so when you can dig back to those
emails you can see this that the
ukrainian oligarchs would go to biden
and this is during the vice presidency
because again people need to understand
the timeline of this laptop right this
laptop gets left in 2020 so it's really
i think of 2019 or so is the cutoff of
any information that we have so it's
after biden has left the white house but
it goes back prior to that but before
biden has become president so the real
question is what emails and text
messages and business are going in and
out of with the hunter biden crime
syndicate now
so we we have all of this evidence
and i think you make a very persuasive
case the evidence that joe is involved
is that hunter biden is being hired at
all because hunter biden is a completely
useless degenerate and so the only
reason that the ukrainians or the
chinese or the russians or whoever would
hire him is to get access to his father
is there a smoking gun can making that
connection which is the most important
connection between hunter and these
shady business dealings and joe himself
i know there are connections to jim
biden to his uncle to joe's brother i
know there are connections to the rest
of the biden family but
can conservatives say we've got
joe himself on these issues
well there's two there's a few pieces
there right um probably the biggest ones
that i would say in terms of that are
we know that
for a fact there is a video of hunter
biden essentially because he films
himself constantly but in one of his i
guess binges he's filming a video which
he's talking to one of his his ladies
and he's telling her
i'm the one who makes all the money for
the family
i'm the one that's bringing it all in i
make the money and they get to go out
and they get to go have the parties and
the state receptions and they don't give
me the respect i deserve for being the
one who brings in the money so people
need to look at this as it's not a
business deal it's a family operation
then you see emails multiple times from
none of that i'll say it dr jill biden
dr taco who is coming in there and tell
she directs
hunter she says
this bill needs to get paid this needs
to get taken care of we had renovations
done at the house in rehoboth
dad needs training wheels put on the
bike no i just made that one up um
but you can see her direct um visa debit
cards right you know those prepaid debit
cards that people will send out
she says you know send a debit card here
send a debit card there there's an under
there's an underlying understanding that
the money isn't necessarily hunter's
money that it's the family money wow
that's that's a really important
connection there because when hunter
gets that that message from jill you
know hola hunter como
that is it well you you saw it referred
to elsewhere in the hunter biden laptop
when he said ten percent goes to the big
guy right right of course that's the
quintessential one that we've seen as 10
for the big guy but but i do think
there's another
there's another family layer to this
that it's it's um you know it's it's
it's not a quantifiable okay this you
know this this money is being directed
directly to joe biden or something like
that but it is an understanding that the
money that's brought in is directable by
other members of the family and being
that that is the case how do the how do
you then as the president united states
separate that out and say i have nothing
to do with this that's totally separate
this is a separate affair when you your
wife other members of the family the
money's being spread around in a way
that certainly seems from what we can
see to be tied to members of the family
well and we know that joe has lied about
this we know joe has gone on the record
and said i have never spoken to my son
about his overseas business dealings
hunter himself contradicted that during
an interview during the 2020 campaign
he's on the plane
that's right plane come on but now but
now we have the voicemail now we have a
voicemail from joe biden talking about
hunter's business dealing so we know for
a fact joe was lying about this i guess
the next question is what else is he
lying about
then my question for you mr posovic the
hell are we supposed to do about it we
conservatives we can look through the
files you know if we can gird our loins
we look through the files you can relate
all of this information the people can
be totally informed but how are we going
to do anything about it and what is it
that we would do anyway well look
conservatives need to i i think take a
lesson out of the playbook that's been
run against them for the last couple of
years last six years or so right that
lesson is it's action that puts points
on the board roe v wade was not
overturned because people were quiet
about it people went out for the march
for life they got judges appointed right
same deal look at what the left put
conservatives through all these years
russia gates uh the kavanaugh debacle
the list goes on and on and on right
we're seeing the gen 6 committee the
show trial of steve bannon which is
going to take place on monday because he
refused to take part in the other uh
witch hunt that was going on under
pelosi right look
congressional investigation right add it
to the list of congressional
investigations i think twitter should be
on there i think a number of things
should be on there but clearly clearly
hunter biden and his business dealings
do i know america
we almost feel like we're scandaled out
right you know it's like we're scandal
weary at this point and so we've gotten
to the point where because the media has
uh been the boy who cried wolf so many
times with these things over fake
scandals that it's almost like we forget
that hey wait a minute this is an actual
scandal these are actually impeachable
if the president united states sent a
million dollars worth or excuse me a
million barrels of our strategic
petroleum reserve to the ccp
while his son stands to financially gain
from that deal i mean that's a direct
actual impeachable offense now again we
we don't know that for sure but we're
not going to know unless we actually
take
this hard drive which is something that
you know you might see in one of those
detective shows or law and order svu
something called probable cause or a
clue if you will if you want to go back
to the hardy boys right there's a big
clue that something might be happening
and it requires serious investigation at
this point i don't trust the fbi or the
cia quite frankly to investigate
anything with anybody that's got a d
next to their name and absolutely not
one of the anointed families of the
elite in this country of which the
bidens clearly are one so we need a
serious investigation into this period
what financial dealings are there what
foreign ties are there what intelligence
entities are there actually look at and
keep in mind michael the fbi has had
this thing
since the very start that's who mick
isaac johnny mcizek the the the owner of
the laptop store the repair shop that's
the first place he sent it he didn't
want to put it through the media and
bring it to you know this whole chain of
like giuliani bannon certainly not jack
vasovic right
he said i'm a patriotic american i want
to do the right thing i want to send it
to the fbi and i want them to look they
sat on it it's been on a shelf and we've
seen no action whatsoever
of course conservatives need to wake up
demand an actual congressional inquiry
into this so then
this raises the political question for
us
very likely
we wouldn't be able to get joe biden
impeached we i don't think we'd be able
to convict him throw him out of office
i'm not sure he's going to last long
enough i'm not sure his term is going to
last long enough and i don't know that
joe personally is going to last long
enough so maybe if the conservatives
retake the house then it's certainly
worth investigating all of this might be
worth impeaching the guy but then when
we are looking ahead to our proactive uh
political agenda 2022 2024
who are the kinds of people that the
conservatives should be pushing uh
you've you have become
probably more influential in promoting
candidates than
most people on cable news in recent
months so who should we be looking at
and what sort of campaign should we be
looking to to bring across the finish
line both this year and in 2024
well absolutely i thank for for for the
compliment and um you know look i i've
said in no no uncertain terms in my home
state of pennsylvania i'm not a huge fan
of of dr oz i think that's that's a
flash in the pan kind of thing he's
recently said that he'll be spending his
summer in his mansion in new jersey
rather than actually you know
campaigning in the state for which he's
trying to become a senator um but i do
think that across the country that was
that we do see politicians that are are
kind of this new breed um i look at like
a uh a jd vance i look at a blake
masters who are coming out there that
are absolutely this this new lifeblood
into the country into the party and into
the movement where they're coming from
this idea that really started with trump
and i that it's pragmatism that matters
it's putting results on the board it's
actually having uh having those results
and then definable tangible results i'll
go back to the roe v wade right
we had so many we had candidates for
years and years and presidents for years
we had reagan in office we had bush in
office for eight years george w bush
refused to actually attend the march for
life and then along comes donald j trump
not exactly the most um
shall we say biblical
uh christian you know kind of guy but he
looks at it as a political transaction
and says if this is what you want then
sure we can do that and we'll make it
happen and of course i'll come speak at
the rally right because it's it's
shifting politics away from just this
sort of like parlor game of uh which
ideology is the best ideology and
actually delivering on the promises that
we said we want to deliver i look at
masters and i see a guy like that i look
advanced and i see a guy like that
there's a lot of candidates out there
across the country
that i think are now kind of getting on
board with this type of messaging but
you do still see some people out there
that are saying oh you know we're got to
send another 60 billion to ukraine and
you know i think it's i just saw another
1.7 is going over and you say okay but
what what did we get out of that right
what did the american people
actually receive for sending you know
it's bigger than the gdp of like um most
states right so what what do we actually
receive from that while our gas prices
are 5 gallon across the country on the
4th of july so turning our politics into
something that's pragmatic not
necessarily and by the way i'm not
saying i just got back from ukraine
right so i'm not saying that you know
don't support ukraine but explain it to
us right explain it to us and give us a
concrete reason and a concrete
definition on what exactly the goal is
and what the um what the result is and
how it benefits the american people so
then looking ahead beyond these a lot
you mentioned masters you mentioned oz
you mentioned vance those are all 2022
races i know it's early
what are your thoughts on 2024
well i think when i look at the numbers
the math is pretty clear that
even though trump is down a little bit
from where he was in terms of the
republican electorate he still has a
commanding lead 40 points up
in pretty much every poll that he's done
so far we're going to run a straw poll
up at the tposa event next week between
trump and desantis in florida so we'll
see how that goes um but i think i i
mean i just look at the numbers and
desantis is great governor like
absolutely love the guy um but his name
id isn't high
really outside of florida and certainly
with other than you know the high
information you know the listeners of
the michael knowles show naturally of
course know about him very well but for
you know for you know everybody else out
there there's they still haven't quite
gotten gotten it you know he's not quite
on the radar yet and so it does to me
look like trump wins the primary and
given where we are in the country i i i
think would be very hard for a democrat
to go up against him and campaign on the
record of joe biden and kamala harris
and try to win so you could see a
situation here
just looking at what my analyst hat on
where trump wins because of the same
reasons he won in 2016. is i i like how
you put that too you say a democrat
running in 2024 on the legacy of joe
biden
as if you're saying
it's not joe biden i'm not even talking
about jeremiah i'm just saying whoever
the nominee who isn't joe biden is going
to be i think there's only three people
that think biden is going to run again
that's biden himself jill biden and ron
klein who's effectively running the
white house the chief of staff right
keep in mind by the way if you notice
and i do a lot of reporting on sort of
the palace intrigue in the white house
we call it the shade war
we do the shade war updates on human
events daily and the idea is that why
hasn't the chief of staff of the white
house been fired at this point right any
other administration you would have seen
the chief of staff you would have been
on like their third chief of staff by
now right the fact that ron klain is
clinging on and has a commanding
authority in the white house is because
simply that he is the one who's making
the decisions he's been with the biden
family for a long time back to the
senate days right he's been around
forever blinking's beer blinking's been
around biden so long blinking remember
he's the guy who came up with do you
remember the tripart partition plan for
iraq
this part for the kurds this part for
the sunni that was blinking all the way
i think it was 2005. again with that and
just got laughed out of the senate right
it also goes by the way to show our
hubris that that we could just decide
where the lines in the borders of iraq
would be that you know the people of the
land i mean wasn't that sort of the
problem in the first place wasn't it you
know after the empire is dissolved yeah
that goes like pinko et cetera et cetera
that's kind of the issue
so picking up where the british left off
so you're saying uh biden might think
he's running but it's not looking great
for him do you have a pick on who the
nominee is going to be
you know i think it comes down to so
there's there's really three front
runners right now um the two big names
are kamala harris and gavin newsom the
problem is kamal harris and gavin newsom
are going to be competing over the same
pot of money being the silicon valley
mult uh just multi-billionaires mega
billionaires in uh in california and
right now they're looking more to newsom
than they are to kamala because they
think that she's got dwindling prospects
she's most likely going to run i've
heard she's gearing up for it that she's
looking at at this as you know well i'm
i'm here what else am i gonna do might
as well just run and uh but i think
everybody kind of knows and the secret's
way out of the bag on this one hillary
clinton hillary clinton is absolutely
looking at a potential rematch she
thinks that um you know this was hers
right i am the first female president uh
i was the one it was supposed to be that
was mine gosh darn it this is a family
show so i'm not gonna go there but you
know this um you know this is something
that she feels that she really can run
and win and i think if there's a rematch
i i just i think she gets blown out of
the water
i really really hope it's a rematch i i
i love when conservatives win high
office
maybe even more than that i love when
hillary clinton loses i ju it's just so
there's something just just kind of
sweet about it yeah something just
delectable really really
actually satisfying you know the things
of this world vanity vanity it's all
vanity
there's something a little more
satisfying when it's hillary clinton
losing i hope we get to see it again
jack thank you sir always great to speak
with you and thank you for doing your
patriotic duty and delving through the
absolutely satanic sewer of of hunter
biden's online materials so that you can
report back on the crimes that the media
are trying to cover up
god bless to you and your growing family
thank you sir see you next time
[Music]
[Music]